sommes-nous vraiment conscients des
coûts engendre notre consommation
d'électricité au quotidien nous avons
fait le test avec André Porlier et ses
enfants alors combien vous pensez que ça
coûte un cycle de la vaisselle incluant
l'eau chaude 80 sous un dollars 25 50 3
dollars
[Musique]
combien pour une brasserie
la réponse Vincent prochaine fois je dis
une scène
quel est le coût d'une douche de 8
minutes à l'eau chaude 40 sous 15 sous
[Rires]
le portefeuille les économies à réaliser
sont somme toute trop faible selon le
comptable pôle Antoine jeté est-ce que
ça va modifier la décision de la
personne qui va ou non partir la
sécheuse la réponse c'est le chiffre les
dollars ne vont pas faire modifier sa
décision effectivement si on regarde le
niveau des économies ça peut être
peut-être moins intéressant que dans
d'autres juridictions où les prix sont
plus élevés la facture d'électricité
moyenne des ménages et d'environ 2000
dollars par année la moitié de ce
montant soit 1000$ et dédié au chauffage
c'est donc là qu'il faut agir pour
économiser de l'énergie abaisser les
thermostats d'un degré permet de réduire
les coûts de chauffage d'environ 5%. on
passe de 22 à 21 5% de la facture
s'envole 5% de la facture de 1000
dollars dont je viens de parler c'est 50
dollars hydro-Québec a mis en place la
tarification dynamique pour inciter ses
clients à économiser de l'énergie lors
des grands froid la société d'État
demande au ménage participant de réduire
leur consommation près de 160 000 foyers
l'ont fait l'an dernier avec leurs
efforts c'est comme si Hydro-Québec
avait eu à alimenter 30 000 maisons de
moins quand on parle d'efficacité
énergétique il y en a pas de sacrifice
c'est des petits gestes qui vont faire
en sorte qu'on ne va pas gaspiller on ne
va pas consommer de l'énergie dont on
n'a pas besoin paul Antoine jeter à
quant à lui installer le système
intelligent dit l'eau qui baisse
lui-même des thermostats à distance
lorsqu'ils au Québec veut économiser de
l'énergie en hiver une économie d'à peu
près
9 dollars pour ce matin dans le cadre
dans le bloc de 4 heures de défi l'an
dernier les clients participants ont
obtenu des remises en argent de 166
dollars en moyenne ça nous conscientise
sur l'utilisation qu'on filme de
l'énergie on le voit sur notre téléphone
on le voit ce qui se passe on sort en
soi ça donne une valeur de changement de
comportement il y a des gens pour qui
c'est important de mettre l'épaule à la
roue parce que ça peut sembler de
petites économies ça peut sembler de
petits gestes quand on les additionne
quand on les multiplie par des millions
de clients mais ça fait une grosse
différence mais que fait-on avec cette
économie collective là on la donne ou on
la drague à rabais des plus grosses
compagnies qu'est-ce qu'on obtient en
échange de ça si on obtient de la
création d'emploi on obtient des impôts
on obtient des services publics plus
forts on obtient finalement un retour
sur l'investissement collectif alors
peut-être que ça peut fonctionner parce
que gouvernement raison nous demander
d'en faire plus je pense que oui chez
les portsliers c'est surtout par
conscience écologique qu'on économise de
l'électricité à chaque fois je sors de
ma vraiment habitué à tout enfermer la
lumière on a un thermostat de
programmable donc la nuit
automatiquement ou les heures où on
n'est pas là le chauffage va diminuer
des petits gestes qui devront être
répétés presque partout jour après jour
pour faire une réelle différence